bonjour l'été se termine et j'espère que
si vous aimez la mer vous avez profité
de la mer moi pas du tout parce que
l'école fou si vous avez manqué le début
cette vidéo est la suite d'une première
partie ce logique dans laquelle
j'abordais la mère inconnue les
créatures mystérieuses qui peuplent les
maires et le fait que la mère fait peur
en gros vous la retrouverez à la fin du
générique et vous pouvez aller la voir
maintenant ou après y'a pas vraiment
d'or puisque on parlera pas des mêmes
thèmes aujourd'hui l'absence d'histoire
antique dans l'épisode qui commence me
laisse sans voix
vraiment trop bien effectivement
aujourd'hui on va plutôt aller du 17e au
20e siècle et donc il y aura même assez
peu d'histoire médiévale à tous un peu
alors c'est parti
[Musique]
déjà pour prendre la mer il faut des
bateaux waouh deux mois de recherche
pour ça n'est ce pas et il se trouve que
ces navires sont longtemps inapte à
aller très loin
jusqu'au 12ème siècle un parent avec les
navires vikings il est impossible pour
les européens de traversée de
l'atlantique et ses grosses vagues ce
n'est qu'à partir des 13ème et 14ème
siècle qu'apparaissent des navires plus
grand et plus solidaire au xvème siècle
est inventé la caravelle qui est à la
fois maniable et solide parfaites pour
traverser l'atlantique jusqu'en asie
entamée avec quoi déjà mais pendant
longtemps au moyen âge les marins
utilise aussi principalement la
navigation à vue on n'utilise pas
d'astrolabe pourtant connu et bien
pratique mais des cadres en plus
aléatoire le temps est mesurée grâce à
des sabliers d'une demi-heure les ans
pauleta et des cordes à 2 permettent
d'évaluer la distance parcourue
tout ça reste assez imprécis sur toutes
les cartes côtières sont encore
largement incomplète la vue est
carrément une unité de distance en mer
déterminé par la visibilité d'une voile
sur l'horizon du coup les tempêtes font
d'autant plus peur qu'on voit plus rien
ensuite on a vu dans l'épisode précédent
qu'assez peu de marins avaient
finalement une vraie vocation pour ce
métier déjà parce que la mère fait peur
et aussi parce que les conditions de
travail sont absolument horrible
l'équipage est serré il dort sur des
paillasses des matelas ou plus tard des
hamacs dans l'entrepont au milieu des
marchandises et des câbles seul le
capitaine à sa cabine quand il ne la
joue pas à d'autres passagers
l'entrepont est humide encombrée par les
animaux embarquer pour servir de repas
au cours du voyage
alors quand le temps le permet les mares
andorre même carrément sur le pont à la
belle étoile
en plus les escales sont rares elles
sont l'occasion de racheter des vivres
et des animaux les rations dont on a
gardé la trace semble montrer que les
marins manger suffisamment mais leur
alimentation est très monotone et les
aliments sont difficiles à conserver
surtout vers les tropiques pour oublier
cette malbouffe
on boit et on fume à tel point que les
capitaines craignent une pénurie
d'alcool ou de tabac requis pour
entraîner une mutinerie
même si je l'état des cales de ce navire
l'absence de rome serait pas ma
principale préoccupation la consommation
d'alcool est telle qu'au début du 20e
siècle
un commandant de marine déclare être
absolument certains que les neuf
dixièmes des marins qui sont enlevés par
la mer le sont à cause de leur état
d'ivresse
une autre difficulté du métier de marin
et de beaucoup d'autres métiers
d'ailleurs et le caractère répétitif des
tâches qui en plus d'être durs ne sont
pas vraiment épanouissante
ça peut entraîner des problèmes de santé
tels que les courbatures rhumatismes
hernie aux maladies pulmonaires ou
accidents de travail amputation à cause
de caisse mme alarie mais de chute du
mât dans beaucoup de registres du xviiie
siècle on trouve des marins de 40 à 60
ans estropiés sourd ou aveugle la
surdité c'est surtout le domaine des
canonniers à force de tirer au canon et
les problèmes de vue sont surtout dus à
la luminosité en mer et recel
et en plus de ça on manque d'eau douce
dont l'hygiène donc on ne manque pas du
tout de maladie alors les marins sont
souvent trop crevé pour effectuer des
tâches superflu genre désinfecter navire
est donc choc tout les vermines qui
passe au pire les maladies les plus
courantes sont la typhoïde qui est liée
à la consommation d'eau ou d'aliments
contaminés par des matières fécales
humaines le typhus également une maladie
liés à l'hygiène est transmise par
l'époux le score but est une carence en
vitamine c
particulièrement présente chez les
marins au long cours et provoque des
affaiblissements fièvre et perte de dans
nos chairs marins sont cependant sauvé
par la découverte de la cristallisation
de la vitamine c au xviiie siècle qui
permet de créer des poches anti score
boutique parfait pour l'apéro sur le
pont et puis il ya toujours les maladies
vénériennes qu'on peut choper lors des
escales mais pas seulement d'ailleurs
tous ces risques rencontrés par les
marins sont illustrés sous la forme de
tatouage puisque c'est largement par les
marins que les tatouages arrive en
europe à partir du xviiie siècle se
faire tatouer les dangers de la mer est
aussi une manière de s'en prémunir comme
une sorte de symbole protecteur à partir
du 19ème siècle avec l'arrivée de la
machine à vapeur les conditions de vie
s'améliorent un peu les escales se
multiplient
ce qui fait qu'on mange plus de légumes
et on risque moins de tomber du mac
quand y en a plus
mais on peut toujours s'exposer à des
explosions de chaudières des maladies
pulmonaires à cause des vapeurs des
problèmes de vue à cause de l'obscurité
dans la salle des machines etc etc
les navires restent dangereux jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en france entre 2006 et 2015
en compte 176 accidents de travail
mortels chez les marins dont 133 dans le
domaine de la pêche
ces conditions de travail plutôt
déplaisante entraîne parfois des
mutineries plutôt impressionnante
par exemple en 1797 a lieu une mutinerie
à bord de la hms hermione un navire
britannique car le capitaine pigot ou
pigeons aimait bien fouetter ses marins
une pratique tout à fait acceptable si
les marins sont consentants certes mais
cela ne nous regarde pas et c'était pas
le cas les mutineries peuvent aussi être
des simples conflit de travail qui
trouve une solution pacifique et non pas
toujours lieu à bord des navires mais
parfois pendant une escale ou même avant
le départ les motivations principales
peuvent être le manque de rations la
cruauté des officiers ou leur
incompétence c'est le cas lors de
l'expédition d'henri hudson en 1611 et
donne son nom à la baie d'hudson mais
incite son équipage à continuer
l'exploration toujours plus loin puisque
l'équipage fini par refuser
il est alors jeté sur un canot avec son
fils et quelques hommes et meurt très
certainement puisqu'on n'a plus jamais
une nouvelle de lui et enfin la dernière
grosse difficulté rencontrée en mer et
le risque de tempête ou de naufrage les
deux vont souvent ensemble mais pas
toujours
si on part dans les statistiques en
france au xviiie siècle 60% des
naufrages ont lieu entre novembre et
février
et parmi ceux-là les deux tiers ont lieu
la nuit ce qui nous donne une idée des
poses de ces naufrages y fait moche et
il fait noir
même quand les tempêtes commence en
journée la catastrophe se produit
souvent à la nuit tombée surtout lorsque
le navire se trouve près d'un littoral
les naufrage au large existe mais la
plupart des naufrages en lieu près des
littoraux voire même dès la sortie du
port pour les plus doués pour vous
donner une idée au xviiie siècle un
tiers de la flotte de pêche basque poule
entre bayonne et saint jean de luz sur
cette petite distance là juste là au 19e
siècle la manche et la bretagne sont les
côtes françaises des plus dangereuses
les causes des naufrages en plus des
tempêtes peuvent parfois être humaine
comme pour le titanic ou costa concordia
ou matériel six navires à un problème
parfois même l'erreur est humaine mais
ne vient pas du bateau en 1786 un avis
rapprochant du port de marseille ne voit
pas
phare censée être allumées et décide
donc de tirer un coup de canon pour dire
coucou on est là effectivement les
gardiens avaient juste oublié d'allumer
les phares ce qui aurait pu être un peu
dangereux et enfin la principale cause
est la météo tempêtes brouillard orages
toutes ces circonstances aurait provoqué
entre 1824 et 1962 13000 naufrage et 1,7
million de morts imaginez le bordel
c'est la tempête ne voit pas grand chose
personne ne sait quoi faire
le capitaine et c'est bien vous tenez
des ordres parce que c'est son rôle mais
il reste plus grand monde pour l'écouter
surtout que certains hommes se sont déjà
jetés à la mer d'autres essaient de
s'emparer des chaloupes et les plus
pragmatiques profitent de leurs derniers
instants pour vider les réserves
d'alcool des officiers certains marins
se met à prier soit dieu soit la mère
dans un sursaut de paganisme promettent
de partir en pèlerinage s'ils survivent
et oublieront leurs promesses sitôt
qu'ils seront sauvés car quand même
tout le monde ne meurt pas pendant un
naufrage la moyenne est de 7 à u
victimes et les catastrophes massive
comme le titanic sont plutôt rares à
partir du xviiie siècle les récits de
naufrage deviennent très populaire ils
sont souvent l'élément déclencheur ou
perturbateurs d'un roman dans les
malheurs de sophie par exemple le
naufrage du navire est un peu le twist
facile de milieux de récits ou dans paul
et virginie qui est inspiré d'un vrai
naufrage et qui permet de montrer l'exil
la survie
toutes ces épreuves qui font trépigner
les lecteurs les naufrages apparaissent
donc dans la littérature mais peuvent
aussi constituer des livres à part
entière les journaux de bord sont
publiés parfois sous forme de
compilation et comme dans beaucoup de
choses populaire il ya une récupération
politique derrière c'est le cas avec le
naufrage du vengeur du peuple en 1794
dans l'équipage aurait eu la bonne idée
de crier vive la république
en mourant de bien braves citoyens une
maquette du navire est exposée au
panthéon les noms des marins sont
inscrits sur ses murs et à grosse fête
al'inverse avec le naufrage de la méduse
en 1816 on est plutôt dans le bon gros
scandale politique et la dénoncer son de
l' esclavage
on retrouve aussi les naufrages en
peinture xviiie siècle dans la musique à
l'époque baroque
bref du xviiie au 19e siècle à part les
marins ces rabat-joie
tout le monde aime les naufrages mais la
mère n'est pas que le propre des marins
la mer n'est d'ailleurs pas propre
retour mais ça c'est un autre problème
fin il ya aussi des gens qui dépendent
de la mer ou qui font face à ces risques
sans jamais mettre un pied dans l'eau
alors tout de suite un point sur la vie
sur les littoraux et c'est parti pour
encore plus de danger est venu de la mer
oui parce que quand une tempête a lieu
au large
étrangement elle s'arrête pas à la
frontière comme le nuage de tchernobyl
il arrive que les ondes de tempête
menace les régions les plus exposées
comme les mont saint michel les flandres
si on part dans des cours de géographie
physique je déménage soit des dates en
1042 une série tempête provoque des
inondations en flandre et en zélande et
d'autres raz-de-marée sont rapportés en
frise en 1218 ça va pour les dates
tu parle carrément de freeze alors oui
ça va le raz-de-marée ou tsunami on ne
sait pas trop où le plus meurtrier en
europe et celui de lisbonne le 1er
novembre 1755 qui tue entre 50000 et 88
personnes et suivi par un grand incendie
de la ville d'autres raz-de-marée sont
bien plus théorique mais font partie des
croyances populaires comme la ville
disent elles se seraient trouvés au
large de douarnenez et aurait été
engloutie entre le 4e et le 5e siècle au
xvième siècle des pêcheurs raconte
entendre encore régulièrement les
cloches de la ville sonné car la ville
existerait encore sous l'eau et les
habitants et jouirait d'une vie
éternelle
d'après cette légende paris coulerait
aussi un jour parce que son nom
signifierait pareil à is well théorie du
complot c'est pas votre époque qui les a
inventés il arrive aussi que le danger
arrive par la mer via les hommes qui
navigue de suez qui attaquent les côtes
qu'on appelle ces attaques raid ou
radial son courant dès l'antiquité comme
en cent quatre-vingt-treize vous l'aviez
de pise est attaqué par une flotte de 40
millions souvent les pirates arrivent de
nuit avec des complices locaux
s'emparent de tout butin qu'ils peuvent
et repartent immédiatement parmi le
butin on trouve des hommes qui peuvent
être vendus comme esclaves ou échanger
contre une rançon
ces raids continue sous les francs les
sacs sont les vikings avec l' avantage
pour ces derniers qu'ils rendent
carrément dans les terres grâce au
fleuve
donc ce ne sont plus seulement des
attaques sur les littoraux mais on va
pas encore parler des vikings et
pourquoi pas on les a déjà vus
regardez l'épisode 7 si vous voulez bref
à partir du xvième siècle ces attaques
reprennent
en méditerranée à cause des navires
ottoman et barbaresques certaines villes
côtières attaqué perdre alors entre 40
et 80 % de la population par exemple en
1798 à calais forte en sardaigne mille
personnes sont capturés en une nuit par
un pirate qui était originaire du coin
et en cas de guerre c'est pareil c'est
quoi je parle du couac à l'eau forte il
n'était pas très forte bref la guerre
bat quand l'ennemi attaque par bateau ou
la côte et les bords sont les premiers à
trinquer
voilà mais la mer est aussi le meilleur
moyen de transport pour les virus
bactéries et autres épidémies de tout
genre on a déjà parlé la peste épisode
mais on trouve aussi le typhus le
choléra à partir du 19ème siècle venus
d'asie la fièvre jaune venus d'afrique
bref pour les gens sur les littoraux la
mer est à la fois celle qui leur permet
de vivre financièrement et celles qui
leur permet de mourir prématurément
parfois al'inverse et parfois les gens
de la côte qui sont un danger pour la
mère va pas parler de pollution là mais
on a déjà parlé des naufrages et si ces
naufrages été provoqué volontairement
par les locaux pour piller les navires
ce serait vraiment méchant et c'est
vraiment peu avérés mais les idées
reçues ont la vie dure en bretagne à
partir du xviie siècle la croyance en
des pilleurs de mer se répand il
s'agirait d' habitants des environs qui
allumerait des lanternes sur la tête
d'une vache et la ferait marcher le long
de la côte pour faire croire à un navire
comme ça démarre un croyant qu'ils
étaient plus au large qui pensaient
s'échouer gentiment sur la plage et
pillé jeunesse cette croyance est très
répandu mais pourtant surtout les
naufrages recensés entre le xviie et le
xviiie siècle en bretagne un seul aurait
eu lieu à cause d'un feu trompeur une
fois échoué les marins disent apercevoir
deux inconnus sur la plage dont un armé
mais les accusés disent qu'ils étaient
juste venus aider
bon j'ai juste voulu rendre service en
plus déjà une vache même avec une
lumière sur le dos avec l'erp à grand
chose encore plus il ya une tempête je
dis des conneries ou non qu'on c'est
vrai par contre les pillages après un
naufrage existe bien en 1768 le
capitaine de l'espérance échoué à une
marche
désolé les bretons explique que les
locaux sont venus aider
l'équipage avant d'embarquer le coffre
du navire aussi et puis quand il s'agit
d'accueillir les naufragés en attendant
les secours c'est pareil l'hospitalité
est pas toujours au rendez vous surtout
que les marins peuvent très bien ses
choix sur une côte déserte et mourir de
faim ou de froid avant même d'être
secourue la situation évolue
progressivement avec une ordonnance de
1698 qui interdit de dépouiller les
noyer ce sympa et avec le renforcement
des garde-côtes qui convainc de plus en
plus les habitants des littoraux
qu'aider les gens c'est sympa aussi mais
parlons-en encore des habitants des
littoraux
pendant que les marins du début
d'épisode sont au large à risquer leur
vie
la famille reste au port et c'est pas
forcément plus joyeux pendant que les
proches attendent en espérant que les
mares avons bien rentré à bon port les
conditions de vie de la famille sont
difficiles et s'accentue en cas de décès
du marin il existe des métiers
accessibles aux femmes de marins comme
teulière nourrissent pêcheurs à pied au
poissonnière ou encore avec le
développement des conserveries qui
payent peu mais qui offre au moins un
métier stable
quoi qu'il en soit la maire fait encore
une fois parti intégralement de la vie
mais aussi de la mort des populations
côtières qui ont tout au moins connu un
deuil à cause d'un marins perdus en mer
dans les années 1970 très récemment par
rapport à mes périodes habituelles une
veuve de douarnenez témoigne j'ai perdu
mon père en mer
j'ai perdu mes cousins en mer je n'avais
qu'un fils et j'ai perdu mon fils en mer
il avait 25 ans il était sur le
jules-verne en septembre 1953
je n'ai plus personne eh bien j'ai peur
pour les autres car je sais qu'il ya
toujours quelqu'un sur l'eau on l'a donc
vu dans cet épisode et dans l'épisode
précédent
la mer est dangereuse l'amertume et donc
la mère fait peur et donc pour s'en
protéger des tas de moyens se met en
place allende de la protection par la
superstition aux contrats d'assurance
on retrouve beaucoup de moyens de se
protéger de la mer dans les symboles
utilisés dans les ex voto et pratiques
païennes par exemple durant l'antiquité
il était courant de verser le sang d'un
animal sur le pont pour se mettre sous
la protection des dieux de la mer cette
pratique sur vie parfois très longtemps
dans les ports de ligurie au xvième
siècle il était encore courant de
sacrifier un mouton blanc et de clous et
sa peau au mas du navire et puis sur les
navires barbaresques du xviie siècle ont
coupé le mouton en deux et en a jeté une
moitié à bâbord et d'autres moitié à
tribord
entre autres pratiques païennes on dit
que réciter un autre père inversée
permet une bonne traversée que croiser
une jeune fille ou un prêtre avant
départ est un mauvais présage
avec le temps les symboles protecteur
payen se retrouve sur les éléments du
navire le gouvernail l'ancré le plus
souvent la proue du navire qui est orné
d'un bélier d'une sirène le but
d'éperons ornés est à la base d'effrayer
les mauvais esprits et de protéger des
dangers avant de devenir un moyen de
reconnaissance
et puis la religion chrétienne se mêle
de la protection des marins à son tour à
partir du 14e siècle et surtout au 19ème
siècle dont l'idée prière lors du
baptême des navires par exemple ces
cérémonies se retrouvent dans tous les
ports de pêche français et sont aussi à
tester avant le départ d'un navire le
curé s'avance alors vers la mer trempe
le manche de sa croix dans l'eau et
appelle à la protection des navires qui
la parcourent et what is dead men nevada
et en plus de ça on construit des
sanctuaires chapelle le plus souvent
dédiée à marie ou simple croix au bord
de la mer ou en haut d'une falaise
c'est le cas de notre dame de la garde
de marseille par exemple
comme ça les marins peuvent aller prier
et si confessé avant le départ ou les
saluer lorsqu'ils passent devant au
bateau au retour d'une tempête ils y
vont en pèlerinage et donne une messe
pour les marins qui se sont noyés la
dévotion va même parfois plus loin que
ça certains marins glisse des billets
dans les anfractuosités de l'église
avant le départ ou emportent avec eux
des cierges du pain béni où des statues
de la vierge pour les jeter par dessus
bord en cas de tempête
ça valait bien la peine de les emmener
ce qu'on emmène à bord c'est aussi les
prêtres directement pas pour le jeter
par dessus bord cette fois on est quand
même plutôt charlie à partir du xviiie
siècle les navires de guerre ont souvent
un aumônier à bord qui prit en cas de
tempête
s'il n'y a pas de prêtre à bord c'est le
capitaine qu'il fait où les gens entrent
malgré l'importance croissante de
l'église dans les relations entre les
hommes et la mer certaines pratiques
restent livia des croyances beaucoup
plus ancienne en bretagne en normandie
on ouvre des tons frêche pendant la nuit
du 1er au 2 novembre pour que les noyers
puissiez rentrer dans les cimetières
existe aussi les murs des péris mon pose
des plaques des dix pages
cette information n'a rien à voir avec
l'histoire antique mais mon quota à
l'écran
plutôt bas dans cet épisode et enfin je
vous invite à vous renseigner sur le
rituel de la proue est là en bretagne
plus particulièrement sur l'île
d'ouessant
lors de l'annoncé d'un décès je vous
mettrais quelques liens en bas si vous
voulez après pour se protéger en cas de
naufrage il existait aussi les méthodes
bien plus terre-à-terre
même si on est en mer les assurances dès
le xviie siècle en angleterre et le
xviiie siècle en france il existe des
assurances qui garantissent les risques
davari mais aussi la perte de
marchandises par tous les moyens
imaginables
lors de la préparation du voyage les
armateurs ceux qui possèdent le navire
font des prêts à la grosse aventure
qu'on appelle aussi un retour de voyage
ou aux risques péril et fortune en gros
si quelque chose arrive au navire il
n'aura rien à rembourser
et si tout va bien il rendra la somme
aux prêteurs plus un petit intérêt il
existe aussi des prêts à simple ou
double risque
un simple risque prend en compte le
juste l'aller et double risque
aller et retour pour faciliter la
navigation jusqu'au 16e siècle il existe
aussi des contrats de concert les
navires partent ensemble ils rentrent au
port ensemble soudé uni
c'est beau à partir du xviie siècle on
parle de convois qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à 150 navires
c'est beau sauf quand tout le convoi se
fait chopper et c'est le cas en 1693 où
une centaine de navires du convoi de
smyrne sont détruits pour une histoire
de vengeance car bien sûr les risques
peuvent être des tempêtes mais aussi la
rencontre avec des pirates et donc
certains marins ou passager s'assure
contre le risque de capture comme ça la
rançon est déjà prête à être versée
avant même le départ c'est aussi pour
faire face aux risques maritimes et au
deuil des familles que la protection
sociale avance dès le xviie siècle et
créer une caisse pour les invalides de
la marine royale qui ensuite étendu aux
marins de la pêche et du commerce
bon la situation est quand même pas
génial mais dès 1791
les marins de la marine obtiennent le
droit de prendre leur retraite à 50 ans
et les marins de la pêche obtienne ce
droit en 1823
il existe des aides pour les veuves et
les enfants de marins comme l'école des
mousses mais tout cela reste assez
faible
avant ça et pour compenser l'absence d'
aides de l'état dès charité et
associations de métier se met en place
dès mon époque
enfin on parle des vrais pères
oui enfin si on part sur des périodes
qui compte pour ce qui est du sauvetage
en mer c'est mon époque qui montre
l'exemple dès le premier siècle avec
l'empereur claude il était obligatoire
pour les habitants des littoraux de
porter secours aux naufragés
oui bah par la suite aussi on repêche
des gens non oui plusieurs ordonnances
française en courage l'entraidé la
solidarité en 1743 par exemple il est
ordonné aux communautés littoral de
porter au moins une chaloupe contenant
dix hommes au secours d'un navire en
danger ce n'est qu'au 19e siècle
qu'apparaissent les postes de
surveillance
d'abord dans les villes portuaires puis
là où se développe le tourisme genre
méditerranée et enfin en 1895
apparaissent les navires hôpitaux
ce sont des navires ou soigne des gens
merci pour cette information capitale
ces navires permettent de soigner de
nombreux marins au cours du 20e siècle
et voyage jusqu au large du canada est
de l'islande pour accompagner les
navires de pêche
ils sont finalement remplacé par des
rapatriements en avion ou hélicoptère et
disparaissent et enfin la protection
contre la mer passe aussi par la mise en
place d'installations sur les côtes et
de code maritime
dès l'antiquité de construisions des
tours de guet le long des côtes pour
nous protéger de l'ennemi dit ouais bah
au moyen-âge aussi on faisait ça
regardez concarneau par exemple c'est
autre chose qu'une tour côtières et les
garde-côtes c'était des charlemagne
sécuriser les cotes passe aussi par la
lutte contre les vagues le sable et
l'évasion par exemple en créant des jeté
pour protéger les ports ou implantant
des oyats dans les dunes à partir du
xviiie siècle pour faciliter la
navigation d'autres systèmes existent
par exemple les phares qui sont là dès
le 2e siècle avant jésus-christ on
continue trouver des tours à feu le long
des côtes méditerranéennes durant
l'antiquité au moyen âge elles sont un
petit peu délaissé amateurs et sont
réhabilités au xviie siècle à partir du
xviiie on invente même le système de
rotation qui permet d'identifier les
phares selon le rythme de leurs lumières
et les premiers phare électrifié
apparaissent dans la deuxième moitié du
19e siècle
la mère peut donc sembler être un sujet
tout bête mais elle peut être abordé de
plein de manières différentes
ça fait un moment dans ma vidéo que j'ai
arrêté de choisir mes sujets par
l'événementiel et que je m'intéresse
plutôt pratiques sociales et culturelles
qui t'a du coup traiter des périodes
beaucoup plus longues que ce que je
faisais au départ j'espère que cette
approche vous plaît parce que j'ai
l'intention de continuer c'est ce qui me
plaît le plus même si cela n'exclut pas
parfois de parler d' événement
historique
dans cet épisode on a donc vu
l'évolution des dents
la navigation des pratiques sociales de
la mer aussi bien pour les personnes qui
naviguent que celles qui vivent sur les
littoraux et aussi l'évolution de la
protection de tous ces gens j'espère que
cet épisode vous a plu et le mois
prochain on devrait rester un peu dans
le même ordre d'idée en abordant un
autre élément naturel et des relations
entre les hommes
et cet élément naturel donc merci pour
tous à bientôt et abonnez vous allez sur
youtube partager commenter au revoir il
ya des matins qui chantent les rêves
qu'il est en tout large score dans le
port d'amsterdam ya des marins qui tord
romeu des oriflammes le long des berges
dans le port d'amsterdam ya des marins
qui meurent plein de bière et de drames
aux premières lui et dans le port
d'amsterdam
il ya des marins qui naissent dans la
chaleur épaisse les langueurs au ca dans
le camp d'amsterdam
il ya des marins qui mangent sur des
nappes trop blanches les poissons islan
il vous montre des dents à croquer la
fortune avec roy c'est là l'une avoue
fait des haubans et ça sent la morue
jusque dans le coeur des frites que la
grosse m'invite à venir en plus pu se
lève en riant dans un bruit de tempête
referme leur braguette et sortent en
rotant pour le port d'amsterdam ya des
marins qui dansent en se frottant la
panse sur la panse des femmes est il
tout mais ils dansent comme des soleils
cracher dans le son des shirelles d'un
accord d or ans il se tordent le cou
pour mieux s'entendre et jusqu'à ce que
tout à coup l'accordéon expire alors le
geste grave alors le regard fier
ils ramènent leur batteur jusqu'en
pleine lumière dans le port d'amsterdam
bien des marins qui boivent et qui
boivent terme bois et qui boivent encore
ils boivent pas la santé des
d'amsterdam ou d'hambourg où d'ailleurs
enfin ils doivent tous d'âme qui leur
donne leur joli corps qui leur donnent
leurs vertus pour une pièce en or et
quand ils ont bien bu se plantent le nez
au ciel se mouche dans les étoiles
et pis comme je pleure sur les femmes
infidèles dans le port d'amsterdam dans
le port d'amsterdam